chris haynes yahoo sports senior nba
insider tnt
sideline reporter he's known as mr
bubble and he joins us on the program do
you have everything packed up right now
chris
oh yeah yes i do i'm ready i ship i ship
things ahead of me
a couple days ago um i'm just i got some
suits in there
so uh you know i don't i'll never root
for pull for any
particular team to win but i wouldn't
mind if it is
i saw where lebron's already up he was
tweeting people at 6 30 in the morning
just to say that he'll sleep when he
gets out of the bubble here
you know you start to realize this he's
been in the bubble 91 days
how many days have you been there one or
two
not that i'm counting but one on two
tonight but dp before i got i got a
pivot just like the debates from last
night you know they asked
ask you a question and they they
answered something else so
to your point about the long ball versus
catching
you know catching a pitch look i grew up
a big david justice fan
huge david justice fan and then david
justice prime
to on his side with him was halle berry
yes now i don't recall you know david
just a big good home right here
i don't recall ozzy smith having the hot
babes you know one of the best defensive
on players we ever had in this game i
don't recall him having the likes of a
halle berry on the side
so with that being said i would pick the
long ball i would pick to hit the
game-winning home run
any day over a game saving
catch i think as good-looking as david
justice was
he could be a light-hitting catcher
and and halle berry would still have
liked david justice so
i think come on
you probably right do you realize that i
did an interview with david justice when
he was with the braves
and i go over to his condo in atlanta i
was working for cnn at the time
and i go over and halle berry's there
and i to the conversation now nobody
knew who halle berry was
i go in we sit down we talk and
you know he says during the interview he
says you know i
i don't it's hard for me to go to bed at
night because i'm usually watching uh
you know sports late at night
and she's over on the couch watching
this and i said
so out of character i go wait she's in
in bed and you're watching me on tv and
he goes
yes and i went what is wrong with you
well we we see why i didn't work out
yeah because he liked me a little bit
more than he liked her
i think priorities are all messed up uh
is there a chance the heat
extended i mean i get there is a chance
but the likelihood
of a game six is what in your opinion
oh god i mean look
the heat are a resilient group um
they fought they fought back and you
know in game four you know i i didn't
expect them to have such a
such make it making such a close game
with bam coming back
for the first time since game one so no
there's definitely
there's no quit in this team and i think
they've shown it all playoff you know
especially all regular season long just
how resilient they are
um but with that being said man look
i felt like if miami got game four
in the series of 2-2 i i felt like
miami may have a good shot at taking it
because i think i think
the way that they're made up with a
bunch of dogs over there
i just think they're probably a little
bit mentally tougher but i
i just think personnel wise especially
with the way miami is hurting
that gives the ass to the lakers so for
that alone
i i think lakers get the next guy i
wondered about this that lebron was
upset
that you know not that he didn't win the
mvp during the regular season that he
got very little respect from the voters
you know that the greek freak ran away
with it
and i'm wondering if those voters
maybe realize or you know if you did a
redo right now lebron would have been
the mvp for the season if you included
the postseason with the regular season
it doesn't work that way
i feel like he might get a little more
love in the bubble
for the mvp over anthony davis if you
have do you have a vote
and if so who are you voting for
i do believe i have a vote right now um
based off right like if it ended today
yeah
after four games lebron probably gets
the nod
uh a.d wasn't he was in foul trouble
game three so it wasn't as effective
but you know it's it's funny dp like i'm
gonna ask you this because i was talking
to my brother mark haynes about this
you know being that i have a vote so
when you vote for finals mvp it
depends on the the voter do you
vote the winner based on
their performances accumulative in all
four wins or do you base it
off the course of the whole seven game
series
i wouldn't have a problem with either
one and they don't give you guidelines
because because every year i would vote
jordan mvp for the regular season
and even though charles won at one time
carl malone won it one time i just said
there's no more valuable person to the
nba
than michael jordan you get to the
finals and i would vote michael
uh he was just but he didn't have like
scotty could have a really good game
but it was still all about michael
lebron can have a really good game but
anthony davis is capable of having some
great games
you might look at this because i said i
hope the voters give
strong consideration to jimmy butler
for just some votes for mvp for what
he's done with that team
in the bubble and standing up to lebron
and company
um you know and if they got one more win
like jerry west won the mvp and this the
lakers lost to the celtics
and and jerry was the best player on the
floor but jimmy butler has gone
toe-to-toe with everybody in the bubble
and taking it ragtag team that nobody
gave a chance to
and i he would be the one that i would
lean towards if you want a surprise vote
it'd be jimmy butler for the
accumulation of everything
but this is lebron and uh i think lebron
is going to be your mvp i think he's
going to have a performance that it's
going to make it easy for you to vote
for lebron james
yeah and i think you know i would i
can't it would be hard
to give my vote to um a player on a
losing team but
um i i i posed that question because
a.d had a a suspect game three yeah
foul trouble and but they lost that game
so i was saying you know
do you hold that against him in the four
games that he won
and if he you know if you produce and
had a star effort in all four games so
that's right now lebron but we'll see
yeah but i
you know i never know because lebron's
so polarizing
that you know do people want to vote for
him do they think it's a great story or
do they not want to vote
for lebron and they want to give it to
a.d because you know
big stage in los angeles nobody knew if
he had this mental makeup
and you know he's played i mean the
defense he played
in the last game like that was a
difference maker what he did on jimmy
butler but
you know we look at the glossy stats
there and i i you know lebron put up a
triple double
and uh you know the lakers win and i
think lebron will be your mvp so
i wouldn't lose sleep over but i i know
that it
you know if you really care about it
then you agonize over it a little bit i
voted for rookie of the year
and changed my vote on the day the votes
were going in
with jason kidd in grant hill
and it ended up a tie chris
that ended up a tie and i to this day
i i was i i still think back and go did
i make the right decision that day
and it was just for rookie of the year
and i said it to both jason kidd and
grant hill
that i did that and i didn't tell him
who i voted for
but yeah it you know if you care about
it then it's a privilege like the
heisman i care about it i get a chance
to vote on it
and you know you're you're kind of
sourcing this out to see what's best
yeah i think you were all right in that
dp
but you know those two those two ended
up having you know great careers
obviously grant was cut
short but you know it was it was dessert
it's like when you look at back at some
of the co-working of the years you could
look back and say
that's fine you know what i mean like
like it was tough to pick you the ones
whether
whether it ended up a true tie though
chris that's what i always wonder cause
sometimes they go
yeah let's just give it to both of them
yeah so i think with finals mvp i
believe it's um it's an odd number of
writers who get
who get the um pick it so there's no way
you can get a code finals ndp
uh what are you hearing about the start
of next season
so according to adam silver who spoke
with us let me see
a few days ago um at the earliest would
be christmas
but it's looking more more like some
point
um the latter part of january and so i
think that's what most players are
um expecting is there anything that is
going to happen before the start of next
season that we should keep an eye on
i mean no i mean i mean we have some
coaching vacancies which i'm i'm kind of
surprised we haven't filled those what
what's the hold up
with indiana with houston with new
orleans
well i think indiana has to see uh
figure out
see what the clippers are going to do
first because obviously that's the most
marquee job that's available right now
and so you kind of want to see what
names emerge from that candidacy
and then maybe you can pluck a few of
those guys over to interview for your
position so
uh you know la clippers they're in the
wind now that's you know desperation
mode right now so they gotta get a guy
who's gonna command respect from day one
your names like jeff van gundy tyron lew
spoke to them last weekend so
uh that that's that's the job i think
the other teams want to kind of wait
and see what happens there i want to
thank you for
joining us as many times as you did and
you know you were always fun
and we we appreciate it i know it's been
tough to be in there over 100 days but
you always had
a smile and uh we we appreciate our
audience really appreciated your uh
contributions and we
we missed the shoes in the background
there they're all packed up and they're
packed they're
getting they're getting they out of here
dp i gotta get home to the y are you
are you home saturday are you flying out
saturday
saturday at 6 00 a.m
[Laughter]
saturday night is date night chris
i love my kids dp but i told the wife i
don't want to see the kids bro soon
[Laughter]
uh thank you again though chris we
appreciate it and congrats on your
success
thank you dp that's uh chris haynes
yahoo sports of course working the
sidelines there at
tnt